hey everyone we are back and we now have
the pleasure of sitting down with George
Church
hello you know thank you for coming on
and talk later
initiate it so George is a professor of
genetics at Harvard University last 32
years as a longtime co-author of
thirteen hundred different notes the
thirteen hundred co-authors 479 papers
for seven papers
thirteen hundred co-authors oh wow so
okay now is this this is really tough to
even find a place to start because
obviously the code of life and what
we're gonna be doing with it what we
have done with it
what have been some of your favorites in
the past 32 years and yeah tell us a
little bit about that some of my
favorite papers some of your favorite
studies Eureka moments yeah well I think
we can go forward or backward let's go
forward in time you know I think when I
was my first few papers were in x-ray
crystallography and modeling of
three-dimensional structures of proteins
and nucleic acids we did the first fold
in nucleic acid that was a and during
that where we had this 3-dimensional
structure I typed in all of the
sequences in the world known at the time
and folded them up and I said wow this
is pretty easy why don't we just
sequence everybody on the planet because
it's sequence data was easier than
slogra the-- it's it's like a microscope
except at that when you get down to
atomic scale microscopes don't really
work so well anymore so you have to use
crystals diffraction it's just that it's
very technical in most physics and math
basalt to do the Fourier transforms but
anyway that was how I started because
you can use an electron microscope to
tell a certain point you can't really do
the atomic resolution of
proteins that way certainly couldn't
back then here he each item kind of
stands out it's very clear it's the best
best you can do so far and what you
learn now that was that was in seven
that was sort of 74 to 77 I was doing
that and those are my first five papers
and you were and you were able to see
actual proteins and the first folded
nucleic acid so so the nucleic acids are
often just just you know just a long
string of a C's GS and T's and then they
fold up and they have functions well I
mean for example functions in the
genetic code so that that particular
start school got me started on thinking
about reading the genomes of everything
on the planet and it started me thinking
about in the genetic code because this
was the crux of the genetic code was in
this molecule and I've been doing that's
been one of the those have been two of
the themes for you know the roommate you
know forty years now
so then as you decided to get really
enthralled with the code of all
different things and do genetics all
different things what else along the way
did you go oh I want to study this I
want to look into this you know well so
the the the code is basically ever every
cell in your body has six billion base
pairs
I carry how much fewer and each of those
DNA base pairs ACC cities gets converted
to RNA and protein and each of those
folds up and the protein has 20 amino
acids and triplets and so along the way
we said oh we know what we have to show
in crystallography was the first fields
it was automated and I said oh let's
automate everything else so we I mean
that wasn't my main thing but that was
something was relatively easy to do from
my experience up to that point we did
DNA and then proteins and then RNA and
then systems biology where you figure
out what it all does in principle and in
synthetic biology where you test your
notions of what it all does and that's
kind of the phase we're in right now
almost everything we do is about reading
and writing complex biological systems
ranging from the atomic level to the
organs organisms and even ecosystems and
you can just you can use the general
basis of one of these very versatile
tools that you can use at all kinds of
scales
it's really amazing to hear about people
that have studied this their entire
lives because you've been studying this
longer than I've been alive yeah and
that is amazing because this is an
exploding area of research and
importance into figuring out how we can
model our world more symbiotically with
what biology has already produced so how
about some more of these epic takeaways
over the last couple decades so yeah so
after those first five plus a lot of
your papers I switched to Wally Gilbert
slab and molecular biology and did and
started working on a new sequencing
method that we called genomic sequencing
which then led to a whole series of
other sequencing methods that get just
kept mutating and during that period of
time we essentially brought the cost of
sequencing down by ten million fold so
yeah think of yeah you know of anything
that you currently possess being 10
million times cheaper most of them you
would not buy 10 million times as much
of it so you wouldn't buy 10 million
cars or 10 million cell phones and that
that that at first that sounds like a
threat that if you drop something like
10 million fold you're only gonna drop
your profit not
not actually but in the case of DNA
sequencing there seems to be an
insatiable appetite and we're probably
consuming a hundred million or a billion
times as much even though it's a lot
cheaper or because it's a lot cheaper so
that was extremely elastic market and
which is fortunate and it will continue
to drop and was that the method of the
saliva separating the DNA from the
saliva and then marking it well you can
get that DNA sequence DNA sequencing a
completely generic method you can use it
for soil use for plants you could use it
for people saliva blood tissue you use
it for forensics you use it for some
ancient DNA and it's a it's it's it's
it's one of these generic it's like
tools it's kind of like the computer if
you use Peter for a thousands of
different uses but your method was mine
was for all of those no I'm they have
been basic methods that you can use for
all these rooms and then in some cases
in my lab was the first to apply it to
some of these things but the core
technology could be applied to more
things in any one lab you do you're up
to some pretty cool stuff now you wanna
teach us about that sure
yeah you want to start with something a
particular just what meat is there well
so see most recently we've figured out
ways to do genome engineering genome
editing or writing depending on how you
want to at all pretty much the same
concept you you need to be able to read
the genome in order to write it so the
revolution is reading and writing code
together we've used that to engineer the
genomes of pigs so that they can they're
compatible with their organs are
compatible
our body sort of transplantation and
those are starting to go into
preclinical trials and then we're
working on aging reversal similar kind
of strategy using the gene therapy like
strategy or for introducing genes that
could be made at a higher level in order
to reverse the loss of the gene
expression over time and we're testing
those in pre aged mice and creates dogs
and the first product will be in dogs we
are working on a way that we can make
any organism resistant to all viruses by
changing the genetic code
so that that tRNA that worked on as a
teenager if you can get rid of one of
those tRNAs it might be thirty or forty
tRNAs in the cell that each decodes a
different part of the code you can get
rid of one of them in such a way that
doesn't hurt the host then the viruses
can't
make proteins can't replicate and so
we've already unpacking a couple of
those so with the first one with organs
now is what about one of growing organs
or right yeah so we're doing that as
well who you are as well all right
and so with so is there a golden key to
the organs to what to what is most
optimal for replacing a heart or
replacing a liver one that's maybe
better than the other methods well we
won't know probably until there's one of
them is in routine use but the pigs have
the advantage that it's very easy to
grow up pigs I mean we do already do it
for foods with you and you can probably
get harvest about a dozen different
organs from one Pig so that's very
cost-effective we don't yet know how to
make a complex organ in the lab of them
say human parts in principle human would
be more compatible but we're getting the
point where we're already getting
so-called universal transplants that you
can do from any human to any other or to
any human to any human without having it
that find a perfect match the way it's
currently practiced and with the pig is
this taking a in vitro so the boy we do
the pig is we take we have a pig that's
engineered to be compatible and then at
the time of multiple human surgeries you
just take the appropriate organs out and
move them into the human that's the the
fully [ __ ] just the way you would for
human and human give a fully functional
heart you move it into a patient who
needs a heart or a liver or a kidney
okay but we're doing or just a straight
pig DNA into human no Pig piano plays
organ pig heart yeah the pig heart has
been the whole pig has been engineered
to be human compatible but you just take
the whole heart out beating and put it
into you and how is the pig engineered
did DNA Wiese to be comes out of the new
Pig is engineered so that its cell
surface has the right carbohydrates on
all right sugars it proteins have to be
not alarming to the immune system
yeah there's coagulation and other blood
components that have to be made
compatible so there's about and and they
have to be made so they don't have any
viruses so that was that required the
most that you know we had to make about
several dozen changes and the most of
them had to do with getting rid of
viruses and we've already done that we
published that and the pigs are healthy
Lu reproducing excellent work and then
gene therapy as well this is a growing
especially personalized dry era P yeah
so gene therapy is kind of a dual
alongside with genetic counseling so a
lot of genetic diseases can be avoided
by picking your mate carefully so about
5% of marriages results in very serious
diseases in the children Wow and and so
that connect that can be avoided just by
dating the 95 percent that you're
compatible with yeah some some of the
things you can do a gene therapy
involved very common diseases like
infectious diseases in the cell anemia
and right hemoglobinopathies
like alsemia in sickle cell and so
that's those are two applications of
ability to engineer you don't show that
and that's uh this is becoming a growing
and growing conversation across the
world is what do we do as we start
tweaking the human body are we running
longitudinal tests as in is it affecting
other aspects of our body if we make
these tweaks and is it going to keep us
in good health down the line you know we
make this tweak because we do want to
eradicate disease that eradicate
suffering that's really important no and
then what do we do about these
augmentations we don't yet know how we
classify intelligence and strength of
your metabolism and things like that you
know yeah what do you know about this I
don't I don't think we're actually
afraid of it augmentation in the sense
that vaccines produce an Augmented yeah
we're augmented relative to our
ancestors I think we can and should
worry about things like inequitable
distribution of augmentation I think
with the vaccines were only available to
the rich that wouldn't be good
that's what smallpox is completely
eliminated worldwide so equity is one
thing we should worry about another
long-term consequences that go beyond
the timeframe of the FDA approval or EMA
exactly we need to we need to worry
about incompatibility you know between
one kind of genetic engineering in
another but if most of it emphasises on
taking the best that the the best allele
you know an existing allele is very
common in the population but that brings
us to the fourth concern which is we
don't all want to be the same we want to
have a diverse population especially
when it comes to neural diversity
neurodiversity right now so we don't
want to all become the same so I think
if we address all those very
thoughtfully and with dialog among all
the parts of society we reduce the
problems we don't eliminate them so how
do we figure out how to work together
because what would that look like to you
an optimal way for civilization to work
together on genetic engineering you know
so we're we're collaborating across the
world well
and we're not hurting each other along
yeah I think that medicine in a certain
sense offers the possibility that we
stop hurting each other at least through
reduce it a bit yeah because a lot of
that is due to inequity well to poverty
and unto psychiatric disorders that that
people don't necessarily want to have I
think we want neurodiversity but you
want to be able to choose whether you're
chronically angry or chronically
depressed and so forth and those kind of
those kind of things lower less poverty
or no poverty and less psychiatric
sorters that are out of our control
would probably lead to more sharing
healthy international relations it's
probably not a panacea but it's a it's
part could be a big big part of the
solution
now how we get there I don't think we
necessarily have to share radically
before that moment yeah I think just a
few people acting unilaterally it can
make a huge change in the world just one
really great innovation and it will
spread all by itself capitalism is a
terrific way of sharing creativity maybe
then it's globalized yeah so what you
need to be careful about is you don't
global on something that's really aisle
warfare well that's that's it's negative
in some sense you know yeah like
diabetes was not a good thing to
globalize that was a bad idea that idea
yeah I mean it wasn't really an idea it
was just it just it was an idea that led
to unintended consequences so we need to
really be very watchful of that because
yes just like individuals can make a
huge difference in the world
has happened with the Green Revolution
and agriculture yes where we now can
support probably twice as many people as
was previously theoretically possible
but we can also go the other way with
things like diabetes other sharing I
mean you know that there there will be
silos occasionally I mean I've created
some projects that that help show that
those silos are not necess not necessary
but just the fact that you show that I
mean some people say oh they're
necessary but then anyway things like
the Personal Genome Project is the way
it shows that it is possible to share
internationally without any strings
attached it's a very complicated
multivariate issue and I think to be
able to work alongside people like you
around the world is gonna be a really
important way to bring some maybe ethics
and some philosophy into the
geopolitical conversations so I hope
that gets done okay what works right
yeah well it's your eye okay how about
would you say that the essence of being
able to pick when
being healthy as long as you want is
that is that essence keeping your
homeostatic capacity at age 15 for until
you're 80 or longer is that kind of the
essence of it now that's one way of
looking at it I mean I don't know I
can't guarantee the our current notions
about aging reversal and longevity will
be intact after the Revolution that
we're going through but probably some of
that what is is close enough to true you
know I think that bowhead whales live a
hundred times as long as as mice - well
that's somehow programmed into the way
their bodies are built and then a date
and then code in the DNA so but we're
not limited natural we can go to
unnatural levels of aging reversal
there's nothing in physics that prevents
this because we are a far from
equilibrium chemical system where we're
just because burning fuel to air and so
just like you can repair a house for
millennia you can repair body from Anya
if you put energy on yeah and these
little tweaks along the way to restore
ourselves back - yeah I don't think
we're gonna learn how to do it I don't
think we learned that much from natural
systems I mean other than inspiration
for it but it's an engineering problem
you know I mean we might be inspired oh
that mountain lasts a long time so I'll
build my building look like that
mountain out of granite or something
right but you don't but they're
engineering principles about exactly how
much granite you need so it doesn't get
knocked over by a earthquake and things
like that you don't necessarily learn
that by looking at the mountain the same
thing with with human bodies as somebody
that is very thoughtful
I can tell you'd spend a good amount of
time contemplating what you're doing to
know to better humanity know what you're
doing are you concerned with the end of
the middle class and the exacerbation of
wealth inequality exacerbated by IT well
I'm concerned about everything I'm
particularly concerned about equity a
huge fact in my lab over the 32 years
has been dedicated to safety and
lowering costs if something's unsafe the
poor suffer the most if something it
we've lowered the cost of sequencing 10
million fold we'd like to do that for
all sorts of things that impact health
and education
yeah yeah I can tell that you care a lot
about that I just wanted to be able to
pick your brain a little bit more maybe
next time you come to San Francisco we
will terr next time we come out here
we'll get in touch and we'll sit down
maybe a little longer to talk about this
no I'll message the links afterward
George thank you so much for coming on
and we'll take care we really appreciate
it